good evening from London welcome to PE
Morgan un sens at no point in human
history have we been more self-aware
about mental health and if stressed as a
pandemic there's a multi-billion dollar
market for the vaccines you might start
your day by swallowing a Prozac before
unpacking your trauma with a therapist
popping a daer pan for your workplace
anxiety and winding down with meditation
or Wellness app at a desperate hope of
getting some sleep if you've got it
there's a product for it we' never be
more medicated more therapized or more
legitimized for confr ing our feelings
and many would say quite right too but
every study is now telling us that we've
also never apparently been more
depressed or riddled with anxiety
something is broken here and the answer
can't be that it's all in our minds a
new study published today said that genz
employees in Britain miss an average of
one work day every single week du to
mental health costing the nation a
rather stressful $1 138 billion dollar
uh pounds a year and to be clear from
the outset mental illness is a deadly
serious thing
like every serious illness it needs
serious treatment I would never question
people who are clinically depressed or
genuinely suicidal but I do think it's
time to draw a line between mental
illness and mental health Matt Walsh
who's been on the show many times has St
an oted debate about this in recent days
when he tweeted that depression is one
of the basic side effects of being
conscious he later said that labeling
negative emotions and behaviors as
diseases is exactly the problem
precisely what the psychiatric field is
done maybe has a point the global
therapy industry is worth $150 billion
and it's growing at a rate of knots
young people in particular are
relentlessly bombarded by content which
gives them every reason to feel
uncomfortable and anxious and the act of
encourage to then vaunt their suffering
is that part of the problem and Britain
used to celebrate the so-called stiff
upper lip I guess that boils down to
being resilient in the face of adversity
if times are tough but we were told to
Soldier on keep pounding in find a way
through it's become more fashionable and
again many people think this is the
right way to go to be perhaps more in
touch with your trauma to get help for
it to talk about it publicly criticism
though has now become recategorized as
shaming disagreement becomes very
quickly described as hate or
confrontation is categorized as violence
is that right it should be no surprise
that there's been a bit of a cultural
fight back hugely influential characters
like Andrew Tate for good or bad I've
encourage their millions of followers to
see depression as a man-made concept
which ironically is unbefitting of
men what do you believe about depression
do you believe depression is a real
thing I can't become clinically
depressed why' you know because I don't
believe in it I can't be haunted by a
ghost if I don't believe in ghosts well
that's saying I'm never going to die
because I don't believe in it it's
ridiculous well he's completely wrong as
I said there and there is a middle
ground though and I'll gladly call out
the esses on both sides of the argument
just as when I question Tate's creative
interpretation of the tears he shed in
jail did you shed tears in your cell
there were tears that ran down my face
but I did not cry I mean that's crying I
would disagree yeah you were crying
Andrew tape maybe you're a little bit
depressed as you sat in your prison C
nothing wrong with that just confront
your feelings but somewhere in his
bombast Tap maybe has a point podcaster
zubie struck a c with me this week
having just returned to the UK from New
York when he posted if you absolutely
believe you will get jet lag and that's
inevitable you will get jet lag I don't
get jet lag well as someone who just
flew back from New York and has jet lag
maybe I should think harder about not
having jet lag you might be right we do
talk ourselves into a lot of this stuff
and we maybe have lost sight of the idea
that everyday stresses and strains are
as much about our ability and will to
manage them as they are about whatever
is getting us down maybe we we've
forgotten how to keep calm and carry on
maybe we should stop thinking that's a
bad thing to be frowned upon a lot of
people making a lot of money by telling
us we're not okay what joing me to
discuss this is my pack talk Tov
contributor eser CRA associate Daily
Mirror Kevin McGuire legal journalist
Ava Santina and we're joined from across
the pond by the podcast host I mentioned
earlier zubie uh zie let me start with
you um because I liked your comment
about jet lag it hasn't worked for me
but I like the inspiration that you gave
me to try and make it work and I'm
working on my I don't have jet lag
skills um on The Wider point it's a mind
field this whole area of mental health
there's no doubt to me uh I've got three
sons in their 20s and I know lots of
their friendship groups there are a lots
of young people suffering from genuine
anxiety I wouldn't categorize it as
clinical depression um it may be in some
cases but just general levels of anxiety
that I don't ex think existing did when
I was that age a lot of it may be uh
phone driven you know being subjected to
endless terrible imagery which we never
used to have to be exposed to When We
Were Young I'm not sure what it is but
when you look at this whole situation
what do you
think yeah Piers I think it's one of
those situations where multiple things
are true at once and people often go to
extremes when it's not necessary it can
absolutely be true that there are people
who suffer genuine serious traumas which
require things like Ser therapy and that
there are people who have real mental
illnesses or severe mental health issues
where medication temporarily or even on
a perhaps longer term may help and that
can be true it can also be true that
many things are being overdiagnosed and
that The Human Condition itself has been
pathologized in various ways and that
there are all sorts of influences out
there which are not necessarily serving
people's best interest interests because
they do make money billions of dollars
and pounds off of certain medications
you said the therapy business itself is
worth I think you said
$150 billion dollar um per year and so
there are very misaligned incentives
here but I do think that one thing that
happens with a lot of these
conversations is people are very willing
to talk about the symptoms but as a
society we don't often go deep on what
some of the causes are we'll talk about
mental health we'll talk about
depression and anxiety but there won't
be a lot of talk about the family
situation and the households that people
are growing up in their friends uh
social networks not not online social
networks but their real social network
are they part of a church are they part
of strong communities what are their
beliefs what are their what's their
physical health status physical and
spiritual health are connected to mental
health so similar with many other issues
we talk about everything at the symptom
level and try to find a pill or a potion
or a therapy that is going to work for
everybody but I think in many cases
we're not really getting to what the
root of the issue is you touched on one
other thing which is the rise of use of
smartphones and social media that's
absolutely having an impact on people's
mental well-being being bombarded by all
these images and opinions and just pure
amount of information every day this is
something very new that our ancestors
didn't have to deal with so I'm not
surprised that there are more young more
and more young people every year who are
reporting that they're having anxiety
depression or whatever else it may be
yeah AA it is a Minefield just to even
talk about this you know I could almost
feel us all you know you're treading on
eggshells with this not to say the wrong
thing not to be insensitive but also to
recognize this survey that's come out
it's pretty shocking that you know gen Z
kids are missing a day a week at work
and the on cost of all that what do you
think is going on here well I agree with
the premise there of your guess uie
because you need to be talking about
like what are the causes of this if you
look at gen Z at the moment some of most
of gen Z are spending up to 60% of their
paid packet on rent they're poor and
they're not having a nice time at home
and I think that really drives into
anxiety and also as you talked about
their phone dependency but yeah I mean
look there is a conversation we need to
be having about self diagnosis that is
going on particularly on Tik Tok
argument I do understand we're not in
the best of economic circumstances but
you know like I said there's less
poverty now in this country than there's
ever been exactly and I grew up I grew
up Rel Absol but the thing is I I grew
up population that we we categorize as
poor but the thing is I grew up in Ghana
and I I've seen triple the amount of
depressed people in this country than
there so I don't think necessarily
material dep I also well of people who
are extremely depressed very riddle with
anxiety I'm not sure that money or
whether you're poor or Rich I'm don't
sure that's really what the core here I
actually think the dopamine impact of of
phones bringing so much stuff into their
heads all day in a way you never ever
had to experience When We Were Young
when I was young you just you didn't
have any phones there was no internet
now if there's a war somewhere they're
seeing you know kids heads being blown
off in real time all day long to have a
bad effect but there was also suffering
in silence after the first and second
world war people came back they were
absolutely traumatized and it wasn't
recognized and their lies were blighted
uh as a result now I love Zubie's
positive view of overcoming jet lag but
it exists mental illness exists but you
have a scale where there will be people
clinically depressed and you'll have
just have other people who feel down for
whatever reason they're in a completely
different category and if we're
medicating them is there a danger that
you talk too much about these things you
encourage people as with everything in
life yeah if there's too much
conversation yeah right and it's pretty
well been wall toall 247 now for a few
years I see no evidence necessarily that
it's working in reducing the number of
people saying they're feeling bad that's
right it's the reverse of not talking
about it and denying it and then people
hurt uh you know real pain problem talk
you can talk yourself into it there's no
we've medicalized real life that's the
problem someone who has lost a spouse
for instance of course we feel sad and
depressed but to say that they have
depression and has to take a pill that's
a problem because you're not treating it
the way that it should be treated real
life happens sad things happen and we
have to have a way to deal with it young
people also lack purpose right if
they're seeing all these you know people
getting rich and having Bugattis online
they're thinking how am I supposed to
have that what is my purpose in life
missing out the Envy factor I mean
bringing zubie back in here
um you know I think all these things
come into play the difference like I
said between when I was young and young
people now is there ability to have all
this staring at them all day long you
know when I was young the most exciting
thing you had in front of you was a
conquer fight you know and you'd be
studying conquers outside in fresh air
we didn't have any phones there was no
internet there was nothing like that um
you you weren't really aware of all the
bad stuff going on unless you watch the
one TV News Bulletin now kids are not
only aware of it they're seeing it in
real
time yeah there are a lot of different
factors I mean social media and
smartphones absolutely play some role in
here I'd say another thing that has
massively changed over the decades as
well is just the situations that people
are growing up in their environment how
many different communities that they're
plugged into and how strong are those
communities we we know that there's an
epidemic of loneliness that we talk
about we talk about the epidemic of uh
suicide particularly male suicide we're
talking about all of this mental health
things and it's like all of the things
that help to keep individuals and
societies sane and stable from family to
Faith to community to um you know the
the sense of meaning and purpose that uh
someone else brought up earlier all of
these things have also been eroded over
the past let's say 50 or 60 years so
when it comes to these situations I mean
why are people so Desperately Seeking
therapists I think in many cases sure
there might be people who really
genuinely need a professional therapist
but I think there are also people who
just need someone to talk to and they
don't really feel like they have friends
or they have parents or family members
that they can confide in and talk about
these day-to-day issues and then it
builds up and it gets to a stage where
they feel like the only thing that they
can do is go to a therapist or take
medication or perhaps even do something
that's far more drastic I mean in the
United States for example I read
recently that 80% of the world's
painkillers are sold in the United
States
80% I mean we think we're over medicated
here my God I mean in in in the US it's
it's really out of
control yeah it's crazy I mean the USA
has I believe 4% of the world's
population and then as you said they're
taking 80% plus of the pain medication
and things like o opioids and the these
things are causing massive crises in the
USA every year over a 100,000 people in
the USA American citizens are dying of
drug overdoses that's 100,000 deaths so
imagine how many other people are
abusing those substances and these are
genuinely scary numbers 100,000 people
dying per year of something that is
completely avoidable um I think that
should be much bigger news but as I said
I I don't know every single solution um
but I think for the diagnosis we have to
go down the tree a little bit and not
just hack at the branches and the Twigs
but we need to get to the root of the
problem and it's not going to be one
single thing it's going to be me
multiple things and I think several of
them have been mentioned
and